strap in Marvel fans there's more Thorin
store / The Hollywood Reporter our forth
or film is on the works the good news
thor ragnarok filmmaker Taika Waititi is
officially on board to write and direct
thor for meaning that he can continue
imbuing the film series with his
signature humor eccentric wit and snappy
dialogue just doesn't make any sense a
nothing makes sense here mean the only
thing that does make sense is that
nothing makes sense the bad news y TT
signing on for another thor film it
means that the live-action adaptation of
akira is now on hold but if you've been
following the development of that movie
at all what else is new right a feature
film translation of Katsuhiro Otomo z'
manga of the same name
akira has been in development for years
experiencing an upswing in may 2019 when
ytt boarded as its director and
co-writer after since 2002 to get the
movie off the ground studio Warner
Brothers finally scheduled it to debut
in theaters on May 21st 2021 quite at
the joining Thor 4 why teeth he was said
to be testing actors in a Talent Search
that spanned the globe and things seemed
to be finally moving forward for a Kyra
and fortunately the film is now on
indefinite hold now that ytt is focusing
on Thor 4 which will reportedly rub
shoulders with the Kyra's plan
production start date with the two start
dates for filming now being so close to
each other it seems as though way white
titi could feasibly work on both
projects it's unclear what will happen
to a Kira while white TT is writing and
directing Thor 4 but thr has reported
that Warner Brothers intends to keep ITT
attached the project apparently on a
long-term basis executives are
reportedly hoping that Y TT will be
commit to Akira after he wraps a new
Thor movie fortunately for everyone a
Chris Hemsworth is lined up to a price
as well as he has Guardian god of
thunder who underwent a drastic
transformation in avengers endgame
Thor's evolution from a cocky arrogant
arrow with little regard for those
around them to a kind hearted empathetic
funny guy who overcomes personal
struggles has impressed viewers but the
new physique eSports at an endgame left
fans divided some loved fad Thor while
others hated him he never did shed any
weight an end game last appearing in the
film with his beer belly and shaggy hair
firmly intact and thames worth couldn't
be happier above us he told variety I
feel like we've opened up such a
different character I feel more
energized for the possibility of where
it could go end game came to a close
with Thor appointing Valkyrie as a
protector of
as guard then joining the guardians of
the galaxy on their mission to locate
Gamora
it's believed like guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 which has director James
Gunn back on board or focus on the
Guardians as they track down their
green-skinned the teammates with Thor
possibly in the mix as well as an ally
or even a new member of the team what
happens in that film could influence a
story of Thor for but with Marvel
Studios fourth phase of the MCU being so
shrouded in mystery we truly have zero
idea what will happen in either film
what's interesting about 4/4 is that
it's the first instance in which an
original Avenger is continuing their
standalone franchise beyond the trilogy
Iron Man actor Robert Downey jr. and
Captain America star Chris Evans each
had three solo films and addition to
crossover ensembles and both retired
their characters with Avengers endgame
this development begs a rather juicy
question that Chris Hemsworth extend his
contract two more solo movies how many
Marvel films that he commits so it's all
very exciting to think about as
Hemsworth floor has become one of the
most charismatic and naturally hilarious
heroes in the MCU arguably only becoming
a serious fan favorite after his jokey a
characterization and ytt saw Ragnarok we
wouldn't mind a couple more for
featuring flicks and we doubt any other
fans would either check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite
superhero films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you